موسم رمضان الحالي شكل مناسبه لبروز عدد
من النجوم الجدد في دراما كنا سالنا
الاستاذ طارق الشناوي ان يضع قائمه جريئه
باسماء النجوم الجدد وبالفعل تجاوب معنا
وسنناقش معه الاسماء
دعونا نبدا معكم ابرز الاسماء والتي
سنستعرضها مع ضيفنا من القاهره الناقد
الفني طارق الشناوي يسعد مساك يا استاذ
طارق اشتقنا لك يومين طولت الغيبه علينا
بالاول
الله معلش هنتعوض ان شاء الله اكيد طب يا
استاذ طارق انت اخترت في المقدمه الممثله
الشابه ايه سماحه عن دورها في مسلسل صفاره
وكامل العدد لك الكلمه
خليني اقول لك انه انا مبسوط اولا انه
اتعملت حاجه ربما مش مقصوده ان الفقره
الفنيه اللي قبل الجدد كانت مع مدام منى
واصف الفنانه السوريه الكبيره
فمعناها ان رمضان فعلا متنوع يعني فنانه
كبيره زي مدام منى موجوده وايضا الفنانه
صغيره في العشرينات من عمرها
بتقدم زي ايه سماح اكتر من عمل
وده هو ده جمال الابداع
انا عايز اقول لك انه
الفن التمثيل
هو اكتر فنون الدنيا تطورا
فن الاداء الممثل وبالتالي الفنان اللي
يحافظ بمرور زمن على قدرته على الاداء ده
بيبقى حاله نادره الفنان الجديد عليه ان
يلتقط ايضا اداء جديد وايه بينطبق عليها
ده طبعا من اصل حظها انها اشتغلت في عملين
اتصور اللي هم ناجحين كامل العدد وسفاره
الاتنين اعمال عامله رد فعل قوي جدا
طيب الفنان حاتم صالح يبهر الجمهور العام
الثاني في مسلسل الكبير اوي والصفاره كيف
تقيم اداؤه في الدراما هذا رمضان
[موسيقى]
حاتم انا لما شفته من السنه اللي فاتت
يعني ايه توجزت خيفه في الاول انه هيبقى
كراكتر يعني هيعمل
تفاصيل محدده في الاداء الصوتي او الحركي
وهيفضل مرتبط بها هتنتهي عمرها الافتراضي
مع الزمن يعني شوفي حركه العين دي لكن
السنه دي الحقيقه برغم انه قرر بعض
التفاصيل لكن لا يزال قدرته على الجذب
وقدرته على بعث الضحك عند الجمهور كبيره
لكن انا بقول له وارجو انه يكون سامعنا
يحاول ينطلق لانه حتى لما راح الصفاره راح
ايضا بمفردات الكبير قوي يعني المفروض ان
انت ما تكررش التفاصيل الادائيه لكن اوكي
تسريحه الشعر برضو احتفظ بيها وهي واضح
انها طريقه مميزه لكن اتمنى انه رمضان
القادم هو صحيح اضحكنا في العملين ان
رمضان ولا يزال تبع الكبير اوي لسه بيعرض
برغم ان الكبير قوي مش في احلى حالاته
كعمل كوميدي لكن حاتم مستمر لسه متواجد
وهل هذا ينطبق على حسن مالك بمسلسل رشيد
حسن مالك انا اكتشفت اولا ده الاخ الاصغر
لاحمد مالك احمد مالك ده ممثل من
الموهوبين كويس حسن مالك انا شايفه في
رشيد يعني يوم عن فنان
عنده تلقائيه وعنده درجه حضور عاليه وتصور
ان دي من تجاربه الاولى والمخرجه هي مي
ممدوح يعني
رهنت الرهان الصائب عليه
طيب يا استاذ طارق شو وضع الفنان الموهوبه
رويا هاشمي اول ظهور لها كان في الهرش
السابعه رؤيا
[موسيقى]
هي فنانه صغيره العمر عندها
شيء مهم جدا ده ما يتعلمش في الكليات وهو
الحضور الطاغي يعني اول ما تشوفيها حتى لو
ماشيه في الشارع لازم عينك هتروح لها يعني
عندها تفاصيل في ملامحها بتجعل العين تروح
لها لما بيكون ده الجزء ده مع موهبه في
الاداء بتعمل فارق اتصور ان هي ينطبق
عليها هذا التوصيف اللي هي الفنان اللي
يسرق عينك قبل ان يقول اي كلمه امام
الكاميرا هي فنانه بواعده وطبعا اذا
الظروف اتيحت لها بتفاصيل ومخرجين يقدروا
يشوفوا حاجات كثيره فيها اعتقد هتتالق
اكثر واكثر بس هي عندها حاجه رقم واحد
انها تسرق العين
ودي شيء نادر
حبيت يعني هذا التعليق بس استاذ طارق اه
سرقه العين سرقه العين لا تعني الجمال
يعني ممكن يبقى جمال جزء منها لكن ليس ليس
هو الجمال لا شيء ابعد من الجمال
انا استوقفني هذا وانتهى الكلام عندي
فاشكرك جزيل الشكر يا استاذ طارق الشناوي
الناقد الفني من القاهره شكرا جزيلا لك
شكرا لك